週五晚上FED主席鮑威爾發表了一番談話
那股市是有非常大的波動
我們就來看一下一個短線的當充交易者會怎麼處理週五的這個盤
那週五第一個遇到的事件是八點半的PCE公布
那這也是一個重大的數據
所以就是這個掛兩邊
然後行情往哪邊發動就往哪邊追假
因為就是我們來不及知道是往哪邊發動嘛
但是AI會馬上去抓那個數據
然後就有很多程式單位發動
那所以這一單是會打在
+257的地方
然後停損20點
然後開寶本
停力60點
那但是在這邊就
回來達到寶本了
所以這一單是
一開始看起來很成功
但是就達到寶本
所以這一單是賺不到的
然後後來就還是上去了
但是因為這邊已經被寶本了
所以是
這一單是賺不到的
然後
再來就是
就是這一根嘛
這一根有超過400孔
那當然疊破就空
所以這個是打在-284
然後它的停損不會是在294+1的295
會是在296
因為這邊高點是295嘛
所以創新高停損會在296
所以Risk是12
然後
停力就會是24
那285-24就會在260
然後
直接跳掉了嗎
然後這邊
哪邊線到260
這邊這邊線到260
這邊就停力24點
然後
然後這一根就是掛
掌過打多單嘛
加256
然後這邊就掌過了
所以
就是
加256
然後
然後這邊就停損了嘛
所以是損243
這邊停損
13點
然後
然後這邊就是掌過掛多單嘛
又一根繼續掌過掛多單嘛
然後
又一根繼續掌過掛多單
這個是
跌破空嘛
因為也是超過400口
喔
從這個地方是開始
那個
Powell開始講話
就是FED主席
然後他講話通常都
就是會有很大的波動
然後他這一次主要是
這一次主要是
是講說
這個
要打擊通膨啦
然後
如果
需要升息的話
就會正常的升息
那
所以
所以後來
後來
好
反正
不爆雷好了
就是後來就是
不是波動很大
然後
這個地方
是先
欸我看一下
好
這個地方是先
這一根被疊破嘛
所以這個是
呃
空
然後
停損是
嘛
然後
這一根
是
被掌過了
所以是這邊
空
然後這邊
兩倍的
打
216的多單
所以這邊是
損6點
共210
多
然後
這個216
多單是
呃
risk是
215-19
吧
是
17+2
19的兩倍
38嘛
216+38
所以是
然後
這邊是
鮑威爾
談話結束
然後
結果噴了一根
54就停立了
所以這邊停立
38點
然後
然後這一根
這一根
這一根是
呃
也是被掌過嘛
黑黑被掌過
所以這邊是
+273
然後
然後馬上就停損了
我按慢一點好了
不然你們被爆雷
然後這邊會
被停損
然後
然後這一根
260停損之後
這一根又跌破
所以是
空
然後
Risk是
因為是
16+2
然後停力是
36點
然後
257-36
這邊就看
這個有沒有長過
這邊是
然後這邊
剛好這邊都沒有長過
因為
這個
這個是
有時候300口嘛
那
長過也是會打多彈
但是
還好沒有長過
然後
就
蠻幸運的
在這邊
停力了
36點
然後
然後這個
又是大量的
紅K
所以一樣跌破
會重新空
所以這邊又空了一個
Risk
是
那
所以
停力是
在200
然後這邊又再
停力了一個
20點
然後這邊又出現一個
紅K
一樣是
跌破空
所以
這邊是
停力之後
又重新
空了一單
然後
185的這一單
Risk
是
加2
14嘛
所以
28點
又再
再
停力了一次
停力在
這個地方
然後
然後這個是
這個下面
看起來是
沒有顏色嘛
不過這個是在
最低點的
綠K
所以長過一樣
打多單
所以這邊是
165的抄底單
然後
停損
就是
然後
下一分鐘就
停損了
又繼續跌
所以這一單
抄底
是沒有成功
就是
停損
15點
然後
然後這邊
這個
就是
一樣是
掌過打多單嘛
然後就掌過了
所以這邊
打了一個
+151
停損是
然後
然後這邊是連續爆大量
所以
這一根
這個
144被跌破
會
打兩倍的空單
然後
這邊
已經開盤一段時間了
所以
量開始變比較少
就是
包圍爾是10點交往化嘛
已經過了稍微一段時間
那
這邊
這個
144也
被
重新跌破
所以是在
這個
10.52分的時候
打兩倍的143空單
所以
剛加152
也被
呃
兩倍的143
就是
停損9點
然後
這一根
的
Risk
是15嘛
所以
停力
是
然後
這邊
又重新停力
然後
這個
一樣是
跌破
就空
OK
然後
這個
又被跌破了
然後
這根
是長過多
不過
沒有長過
那
所以這邊
就是會掛兩邊
就是
出價多
跟
出價空
然後這邊
空了一個
就是
的空
然後
這邊
是
如果這根
長過
就出價多
蛋嘛
所以是
出價多
然後這邊
就打到
所以
空單
在
地方
就是
出價多
蛋
然後
停損是
那個
就是
這一根的低點
如果又跌破
然後
這邊就跌破
所以
這一個
當然是
停損
12點
然後
這一個
這幾根也都是
長過
做得多嘛
那最後這根被長過
所以是
+85
然後
這個
+85
是
Risk
是12
所以
停力是
然後
這邊到最高
只到
就是
沒到109
就又下來了
那
因為是
摸底單啦
就是
最低點
所以
是
沒有開寶本
然後
喔
然後這邊
這邊就被反向了
因為這邊有一根
396口
就是
它雖然不到400
但通常
通常
不會那麼嚴格啦
396會
會當400
然後就會
就會打
反向
反向空單
所以
在
這個地方
就打了一個
反向
跌破
這個
88嘛
所以是
87空
然後
這一單空單
就被停損了
就是後來
這邊有到
那但是
就是因為我們
已經打了反向嘛
所以這邊是
一個
減
087空
然後
停損
所以
也不是說
就是都是打
一直打空單就會成功啦
因為
畢竟
還是會有一些波動嘛
然後我們打的是比較短線的交易
所以
這邊
就是
一個
這樣的反向
然後
這一根是
呃
減
106嘛
然後
Risk
是
那
所以
呃
Risk
是15
所以是
30點停力
停力
然後
這邊也順利的到
這個是
這一根是
一樣
漲過打多單嘛
所以是
多單
然後
跌破
65的話
就停損
然後
這一單是
過了一個小時
才停損
就是從
呃
00.31
然後
到
欸
進場
是在
43吧
這邊
00.43
然後
到
過一個小時之後
就是
1.44
才停損
所以這邊
就已經比較低量了
然後
後面
就都沒有再有
400口
以上
的大量
那
後來
收
是收在
很低喔
就是到
4點
凌晨4點
每股收盤之後
這個
可能多單又開始認錯停損了一段
後來
後來是收到
最後
成交價是
就是
每股收盤之後
還又再跌了60幾點
那
主要還是
市場對於升息的
預期是
是出現啦
就是
如果多升個
一馬的話
這個對市場
就是
股市估值的
縮水影響
還是滿大的
那
所以
雖然還沒有升息
但是
鮑威爾這
談話也是
有很大的影響
這樣
然後
就是
好
反正就是
最後這些
全部加起來
是
正81點
看一下
好
就最後
給大家看一下
昨天的
復盤
就這樣啦
掰掰